take a look at dylan that peter's
numbers this year 18 innings of work 338
era not too shabby
oh two a wave and a miss struck him out
so two outs
fly ball to right
camel
that's the way to do it yeah
very easy in it if you want excitement
all you have to do is put wade miley on
the mat he keeps the game going he's not
going to put you to sleep very quick
between pitches and he's gonna throw
strikes
oh right up the middle of both clubs are
coming out swinging that shillely as
you're what he built they might say two
on for sutsugo
goes it safely in six of his last seven
ball games
there's a lighter over second into right
base hit hayes touches third he's on his
way home castiano's with the throw it's
cut off reynolds is able to take third
on the rbi single by suzugo it's one to
nothing pirates gonna swing in a liner
that's into right base hit stallings
comes through with a two out single and
the pirates do pick up that second run
it's two to nothing
alfred chops it to third and booted by
suarez
they don't look like they're trying for
a wild card spot no
david bell probably not pleased
lion drive to right field another hit
stallings does not run well but that
ball will take about four hops before it
gets to castiano's
pirates capitalizing in a big way here
three nothing
here's the 3-2 swing and a miss he
struck him out threw him to change up in
the zone
[Applause]
that's past hayes
suarez up to second
slams on the brakes to shields halfway
retreats to first and two are on with
two down
and reynolds back a couple of steps
do it
ball to short farmer flips to india
around novato and that's a one two three
inning kind of it's an ending ending
double play
two outs base is empty
swinging a ground ball on the short two
hops for newman's got it cleanly tossed
across for the out the inning is over
three ground ball outs for dylan peters
boys blank cincinnati through the first
three
there's a fly ball to right
that's the final out here in the third
the reds have got to figure out a way to
crank this offense back up two and two
motto fair ball
that's going to be the first extra base
hit for the reds as vano lefty lefty
doubles the opposite way
tying run at the plate aquino struck out
his first time
oh goodness
that's ball four
that's base is loaded
[Applause]
two down
shortstop
newman to
the reds leave a couple nothing across
it's this hard aquino
over his head
and ben gamil is two for two
a little huge shot squibber and it's
gonna go as a hit
[Applause]
first and second
clean bravado
o'malley
some magic strands a pair let's see if
the reds can get some runs
reds haven't scored since the third
inning of saturday's game in st louis
and farmer gets it through
and farmer yanks one pull side for a
base hit and now with two outs here
comes nick castianos representing the
tying run in the fifth
blind right to third
for the final out
two more left on frustrated reds team
trailing three nothing now it's first
and second and nobody out
and it's through the hole a base hit
newman will score
four nothing pirates and reynolds races
to third the ball gets away and setsugo
will go to second and reynolds will
score
five nothing nobody backing up the throw
to third
[Applause]
and this ball hit hard that's a fair
ball
suzugo will score
stallings to second with a double six
nothing lead off walk often a good omen
for the offense
suarez smashes one through the left side
first two are on
and that is throw base hit
schrock singles to low to the bases
barnhart with the bases loaded does have
a grand slam he's three for 10 bases
full this year
barnhart and a breaking ball shallow
right it's going to drop in base hit
botto scores on his heels suarez he
scores and the reds get their first two
runs of the night it's six to two bases
loaded again the tying run bats in
jonathan indian
grounded to hayes second one
not in time schrock scores
the reds third run of the inning it's
now six to three
first pitch to right field
and it gets by gavel on the dive
barnhart scores
india over to third a 6-4 game what a
response from the reds go ahead run at
the plate nick castiano's the ninth red
to hit this inning
and long
top of the sixth comes to an end
and there we go there's the inning yeah
that might allow shelton to go to shreve
for the eighth
to third base
[Music]
two perfect innings from luis sessa
helping to keep this a two run game
how about chasing shreve five up five
down
shreve is gonna go two perfect innings
what a relief
and coming on to try to save it here
comes chris stratton
stratton gets the rookie swinging
first pitch
deep right center and gone
castellanos cranks a two out homer with
the reds down to their final out and his
29th bomb makes it a one-run game
yes chris stratton
saves it and raises the jolly roger
and the pirates hold on they beat
cincinnati six to five here in the
series opener